[Music]
[Music]
what are you doing I am scheduling our
trip to Taiwan so if you guys don't know
Mariel actually lived in Taiwan for what
two years mm-hmm she lived there for two
years and one of the biggest reasons why
I'm going here is because she wants to
show me the reasons why she loved this
place so much and why she considers it
her second home I mean there's really no
reason to like dislike the place because
the food's good it's cheap people are
nice you got family more I guess with
potatoes
you got guava Fenton and Samantha and
time what is the thing that you think
best represents Taiwan that I'm just
going to love mmm I think just walking
around seeing people go to these night
markets I think you'll just be kind of
surprised like how normal it is whereas
here yeah like night markets are big
events we're like super super proud in
there for like it's not normal right
here it's like a daily life thing and I
don't know just because I have so much
memory there I just want to walk through
the memory with you and I hope you like
it
yes Megan that's your hand you didn't
wash your hand I did wash my hands I was
in the bathroom I'm peeing
yeah what do you do after you pee I
don't know you tell me you watching it
even here the sink oh yeah you're good
to you
ah you draw this
good morning you ready all right you
ready for Taiwan yeah oh my I'm so tired
I can't even oh we are waiting for our
uber the app always messes up for some
reason every time I put current location
it puts it to a location near me but not
where I'm at and so it's [ __ ] me over
on rise right now we're waiting Thank
You Hoover suddenly lift sounds a little
appealing
[Music]
okay so we're first we're gonna go to
not ETF for about two hours or so
stopping off in Japan uh-huh having a
little layover net will arrived and tall
unit court around 7:15 and then we'll
get our offspring and pop there
off-screen offspring all the yep
children okay excuse me and pocket Wi-Fi
those are two things at least you get
out the air for work
[Music]
Oh yet I tell you an airport oh we met
the craziest airline experience ever
there's supposed to be a lot more
footage but on the way to 95 depend on
at the airport
I actually got food poisoning it was so
funny because number one we were just an
economy bus we weren't supposed to go to
the business class or the first class
bathrooms but I got so sick like my lips
started turning light my skin to start
trying to parallel with sweating I
started getting all into body aches and
I don't like throwing up so literally
what happens I walked over to the
business class bathroom to try to stop
him I let it out it listen I'm gonna
[ __ ] throw up I go inside and I know
the people are waiting for me outside so
I didn't want to throw up too loud I had
projectile vomit living with like all
over the place so the whole time I'm
just like projectile vomiting everywhere
and I'm still sick I'll try to clean up
the bathroom because there's barf
everywhere inside the first-class
bathrooms I would get a bar I would
clean it and I had diarrhea everywhere
I'll clean up the diarrhea then I would
walk again I do that literally five
times oh my god those gorge that luck
has taken over 3/4 of your head we had a
two and a half hour delay we somehow
barely made it back but the great thing
is it's not I don't have really crazy
bad luck because we had that nice lady
who said that we just said we could
switch our seats and then we had a whole
road or so so she was super chic I was
like absolutely no reason why she had to
do that I was so nice of her and because
of that now
better because you had her actually a
good sleep I was it was so we just got
through customs and immigration so
there's a couple of things that I do
when I go to a foreign country right off
the bat
number one I always get a Wi-Fi router
here the reason why is because when you
go to a foreign country I know a lot of
you are a bit scared out there you think
that well because I can't speak the
language I can't communicate to anybody
well here's the thing you got a Wi-Fi
router you have the internet and use
translators you can find a way to get
around with that and you're basically
okay so travelling is super interesting
because of that and the second thing
that I do is that I make sure that I go
to a bank inside the airport because I
want to have the cash before I leave
because I don't want to go around
looking for a bank but I can't even
speak the language and it just becomes a
little bit more difficult when I could
just get it right here as of right now
Mariel is getting the Wi-Fi ones I'm
talking to myself in front of a bunch of
people this is this is I don't know how
you vloggers do this
[Music]
we just made it to the Airbnb that we're
staring at staring at God Jesus staying
at I'm gonna do a little tour for you
guys tomorrow I still have the body eggs
from all the throwing up and pissing out
of my butt crack just to put it in
perspective the place that we're staying
at is right outside all these street
food vendors and I'm sick I don't have a
appetite even the thought if it makes me
sick but I smell that and it was amazing
I heard Taiwan has some of the best
street food so I can't wait to dig into
that tomorrow night tonight I'm just
gonna have some medicine some fruits
just to kind of calm my stomach down and
then go to sleep and then see you guys
tomorrow
Taiwan seems to be a very special place
for Mariel if she calls it her second
home so I really did want experiences
with her and it seems that even though
there was a two and a half hour delay
I was crapping my life out throwing up
having like projectile vomit all over
the place it already seems like it's
going to be pretty awesome aside from
the fact there was a bunch of mainland
Chinese at the airport cutting and
pushing and all the garbage just stop
stop
[Music]